hello so we were having the great debate
over here if the dress was like brown or
black because it was hitting the light I
loved it it was hitting the light when
you turn it is okay I love how it hits
the light it's beautiful so we saw you
post pictures of the Bob on Instagram we
know that it was a wig did you take her
with you at the end of the series and
does she have a name her name is Wiggy
and yes I took her with me what are you
gonna miss most about this whole
experience with this motley crew that
you have let me tell you I'm gonna miss
the people that I work with more than I
can articulate the man next to me
plays Jonah Ryan and Jonah is a terrible
human being but he is not a terrible
human being he's a he's an angel
and I I can't tell you how much I love
these people here so I miss them already
I'm so happy to be here with them now
this is bittersweet for me this whole
thing because I am a true-blue fan of
the show it's my favorite show on
television I love it so much and my head
is saying okay I get it but my heart is
saying why I don't like this at one bit
I don't like you leaving I feel like
there's so much to talk about so many
stories to tell and I don't want you to
go thank you I do I feel like there's so
much meaning even I've seen a couple of
episodes from this in their last series
and I'm like oh you guys are introducing
some stuff to me that I can grab on to
for you oh good I'm glad to hear that
well the idea is to leave them wanting
more so we're leaving you wanting more
I love that so much okay and and finally
you know when you think back on that
last day and think about what you guys
did and how emotional it was and what it
meant does it get any better than the
experience you've had I'll let you know
but the experience that I've had on this
show has been sublime and I consider
myself to be very lucky really an
unsurpassed creative journey filled with
it was a huge labor of love it took a
lot of hard work I'm not saying it was
easy but at the end of the day was just
chock-full of joy long live Selina
Meyers I love her face-to-face I can
convince anyone of anything that's
actually incorrect you're both wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]